hey everybody we have a breaking
development for you this is a recipe
that is not on our cookbook that's very
common or you care so we thought we
teach you or just show how to make your
own cranberry sauce it's really easy so
I'm gonna put a container of cranberries
doesn't really matter you don't really
have to measure these dried no those are
fresh what about these big crab those
aren't days those are dates I'm just
gonna add a few of those for fun okay
so we're gonna put the cranberries in
oops I'm gonna save us some cranberries
for another blended drink but I'm gonna
make it for myself later we're gonna put
in about four dates and everybody you
know taking the seed of cranberry sauce
that you buy in the store horrible
it's basically entirely sugar that's why
it tastes so good because cranberries
are so bitter so no this tastes really
great and is it good for you so I'm
going to use organic apple juice and if
you can see I've just about covered the
cranberries just you can just see the
liquid forming and they need to cook for
a little while so with cranberries
you're gonna cook them on pretty high
heat and they're gonna start to boil
down and make kind of a sauce or a jam
so we're gonna let that sit on the fire
for a little bit and are the stupid
question yes
so for not eating turkey yeah
Thanksgiving
we using brain cells for for everything
it's the it's a flavor of Thanksgiving
and of the holidays there you go so you
eat it as a con it's sort of a chutney
or condiment so it'll be on the side of
our vegan mashed potatoes and our
mushroom gravy and our mixed green pilaf
and our two wat cakes and it'll be
better than and your turkey I'm very
grateful Aunt Betty
she like should I have she'll like it
she might not admit I know you can never
make her happy okay so we have to let
this cook down that uh that's ready
cherry pie filling no it's pretty very
soft okay so it's reduced down quite a
lot you can see it starting to get
really nice coughing how long is up in
cooking it's about ten minutes okay so
it's all starting to reduce down so now
at this point I'm gonna add 1/2 a cup of
organic maple syrup
you need the sweetness because the
cranberries are very bitter I'm gonna
add about a teaspoon of cinnamon okay
and I've taken it off the heat I'm just
gonna let it set up so don't taste test
this now or you will burn yourself so
we're just gonna let it sit some of the
cranberry pieces are still whole which
is nice can you put a stick of cinnamon
in there instead um you could you would
want to fish the stick out and if you
can tend to be bitter if you don't
measure it right so I would just not
it's more easier to do it this way do
you like some of these figs I'm trying
to contribute
I was feeling it was feeling insecure
because I wasn't I didn't have anything
to say see you thought that so
interested that you saw one contribution
at your house awesome anyway smell it
though you don't eat it but smell it
it's really nice actually is yeah and
all my boys love cranberries
my house so I have to make extra okay so
what we're going to let that sit and
cool down and we'll use it later